All right Michael, so here's boosting in pseudo code. Okay,
let me read it out to you then you can tell
me if it makes sense. So we're given a training set.
It's made up of a bunch of xi, yr pairs. You
know, x is your input and y is your output.
And for reasons that'll be clear in a moment All of
your labels are either minus one or plus one. Where minus
one means not in class or plus one means you're in
a class. So this is a binary classification task. That make sense?
>> So far.
>> Okay. And then what you're going to do is,
you're going to loop at every time step, let's call it
lower-case t. From the first time step one, to some big
time in the future. We'll just call it capital T and
not worry about where it comes from right now. The
first thing you're going to do is you're going to construct a distribution.
And I'll tell you how in a minute, Michael. Okay, so,
so, don't worry about it. And we'll just call that D
sub T. So, this is your distribution over your
examples at some particular time T. Given that distribution, I
want you to find a weak classifier. I want your
weak learner to output some hypothesis. Let's call that epsilon
sub T. The hypothesis that gets produced to that
time step. And that hypothesis should have some small error.
Let's call that error Epsilon sub T, because it's a
small number. Such that it does well on the training
set, given the particular distribution. So, I'm just rewriting
my notion of error from, the other side of the
screen. So there are times we want you to find
a weak classifier. That is, we want you to call
some weak learner that returns some hypothesis. let's call
it h sub t that has a small error. let's
call that epsilons of t. Which is to say that
the probability of it being wrong that is disagreeing with
the training label is small, with respect to the underlying distribution.
>> So just to be clear there, the epsilon could
be as big as slightly less than a half. Right? It
doesn't have to be teeny, tiny. It could actually be,
almost a half. But it can't be bigger than a half.
>> That's right. And, and no matter what happens.
Or even equal to a half. but, you know,
we can assume, although it doesn't matter for the
algorithm that the learner is going to return the best one
that it can. With some error. But regardless, it's
going to have, it's going to satisfy the requirements
of a weak learner, and all I've done is
copy this notion of error over to here. Ok?
>> Awesome!
>> Ok. So, you're going to do that and you'll do that a whole bunch of times
steps, constantly finding hypothesis at each time step
h sub t with small error epsilon sub t constantly making new distributions,
and then eventually, you're going to output some
final hypothesis. Which, I haven't told you yet how
you're going to to get the final hypothesis. But that's
the high level bit. Look at your training data,
construct distributions, find a week classifier with low error.
Keep doing that you have a bunch of them
and then combine them somehow into some final hypothesis.
And that's high level of algorithm for boosting, okay?
>> Okay, but you've left out the two, two really
important things, even the part from how you find we,
weak classifier, which is where do we get this
distribution and where do we get this, this final hypothesis?
>> Right, so let me do that for you right now.